こんにちははじめ冊はです今日はねきっとねあんまり面白くない動画だからね
シャーペンに興味ない人はお帰りください
今の子って名前です今日は政府をサーフィンの紹介だ
テンション上げていこうねええええグレードロフトで買ってきましたくら吹き矢
戦ですグラフギア1000きました政府予想ペンの大米誌グラフギア1000本当にね
コメントではツイッターでも初めてだと僕の使ってる
もうメインウエポンは
グラフギア1000ですっていうかもたくさんいたし初めて吸わせ税のシャーペン使わ
ないんですかって言ってくださいからたくさんいました
せいぜい良さテレビ
うん
なあはいはい薄すっげ
ディティールを見ていきますよはいこんな感じになっておりますやっぱええええなぁで
0.5
すごいね細身のシャーペンなんですよグリップがちょっとだけゴムのつぶつぶがついて
いますでペン先は修道ができます
ころってこの歩行話したらこうしたら
ペン先も
引込っていう感じです
素晴らしい実に素晴らしい製図用シャーペンでペン先が引っ込むのはとてもありがたい
ことなんですなぜかというとせいぜい予算ペンのペン先がすべてとても尖っているん
ですよ
せいぜいはなんで手元が見やすいように正確に描けるようにペン咳が止まっていてこう
あります
公開ている時もすごい一点主義ってに集中できるんですよ
すごい正確に書くことができる
は製図用シャープの特徴なのでシャー芯が出るペン先が尖っていると鞄とかポケットに
入れた時にこの先2が折れちゃう時がよくあるんですよ
それを防止するためにグラフィア戦は収納できるようになっておりますさあペン時代も
全部アルミでできていてとても交通量かなというかかっこいいです
しびれます
普通のシャーペンにはない感じがあります動く音一にグラフ1000使ってたんですよ
ペンの政治のシャベグラフ1000ってやつがあるんですけど
あの出版って失せしたインっていうさあ心眼分茹でしたいんですあたしがあるんですよ
その便利が出せる写真があるんですけどそれの発売と同時に限定生産された
ブラグ線の限定カラー品のレッドオーブが手に入れてるんですよ
hulu を右折上限定ですよそれをちょっとグラフ1000使ってたんですけど使い
やすかったです
使いやすかったですけど
グランディア2本体細いんでも手がデカいって
そたかなさを不正強さとあんま使わないんですよね
手がでかいからなんか細いペン持ってたらすごい疲れちゃう裏付箋は細すぎてあんまり
僕には合わなかったんですけれども
グラフギア1000は
うん
思ったより細くないです鉛筆の一回り太いぐらいちゃんとゴムのグリップもついてるし
結構いけるかなって感じですゴーグ力高めですね
ちなみにこのぺんてるのが製図用シャーペンのナンバリングっていうのは全部値段に
基づいています多分
グラフギア500というのがあるんですけどこれの
1個グレードしたのモデルなんですけどグラフギア500では500円でこれも2匹
打線はだいたい声援くれる
入っておりますちょっと書いてみましょういやーや貯金とするコラボペン先やば
いっしょこの尖り具合
いやー書きやすい便すぎ引っ込むタイプのシャーペン力すごいブレるんですよ国会で
たら
コックグラグラグラってないんですけどグラフィギュアはペンが引っ込んまで全然そう
いうことはありませんだか正確に描けますね
シーズよっていうだけで図を描くときとか書きやすそうですいいですね
ただグラフギア1000のザク店なんですけど
シャーベットで重心がどこにあったら書きやすいと思いますか
興味ないはい実はですね重心はいえばまんだけどちょっとした日の方がやっぱり持つ
特化したのはを持つんですよ
なんで重心が下のかき汗っていうのがまあ普通なんですけど
グラフギアの場合はちょっと上の方に重心があるのでそこがでたまに指摘されるんです
よねグラフギア1000の弱点というか
重心がちょっと4ch で少し
普通のサーフィンと比べでは書き味がちょっと違うんですよまぁそこはなれでカバー
できるということで
ふくらはぎ打線
つまら概要します
せいぜい良さではグラフ1000の方が好きという人もいるし
せいぜい者別府今と言って出してないんでスマッシュとか
藍色と ssd とアイスシリーズもあるしまだちょっと北3回だけなんだよ
ぜひ
おすすめのやつがあったら教えてください
全部受け動画う
しびれるねぇ
the
ef